like a bit love on a Sunday because
especially this year because its course
a leap year valentine's day may have
come and gone but because it's a leap
year tomorrow and it means traditionally
at least that women can propose to their
male partner rather than the other way
around Holly Patrick did just that
proposed to Pete bars I also here in the
studio is editor of brides magazine
j.pierre morning all three and Pete did
you dare say no no well of course not no
chance man and I wonder though Holly if
why you wanted to do it was it because
he was being a bit slow on the uptake no
don't that I'm so glad you said that
because no with that was not yes it was
just a generous can't came to me one day
and everything with it being leaked get
us there just encourage me to do with
did you do you not feel like you missed
out on traditional proposal no no no no
I don't think I'd be very good at being
opposed to I think I'd be like oh get
out what are you doing look no I
wouldn't like it so I think you skip
that it was me that did it I think it's
he gets to then have that kind of like
glue my mentor offer me see I always
advise I mean I've been mad for for
quite a while now 20 years you're gonna
so twice just the once 20 years but I
always advise young couples that women
let's say to me all he hasn't asked me
yet he hasn't asked me yet why wait why
are you waiting if it's something that
you want to do it's not yeah exercise
you don't have to sit there well that's
it exactly she did me a favor Spencer do
it I think what would you have looked up
the courage at some point P oh yeah was
it was definitely something I was
thinking about and then we had spoken by
in the past and then well she just stem
sort of helping situation a little bit
now I don't have to do it sorry when is
the big day by the way um November right
are you gonna love honor and obey their
like that word you die so that's right
just wondering I'm just wondering who's
faster heaven Jade I mean it's
interesting is that he'll obviously we
think of leap years is the only time we
intend to do they must happen quite a
lot though surely it does and i think
you know our eyes were really open to
that when we started this whole project
because we did a call out across the
brides magazine social media channels
and we were inundated with women that
wanted to do it so you know that kind of
said to us that there was a need for it
you know women wanted to do it there's
absolutely no reason why you know a
woman can't propose to a man now it's
absolutely the damn thing and the women
was so confident throughout this whole
process they came to it for a whole
different host of reasons they all had
different reasons for wanting to do it
but they were all really determined and
really confident and didn't give us any
worries at all really I wonder what do
you think about tradition though in the
sense that oh that you there is this
idea that a man has to propose but also
you know getting permission from a
parent from the bride's father first on
that something yeah this throws it all
out the window presumably a bride
doesn't ask permission from the
bridegroom's parents because yes
Simmental that that's that's kind of the
great thing about doing it as a woman
because it is a rule what is it all
outdated that sort of tradition do we
need to forget about it anyway well i
think you know most people do now I mean
everybody gets married and proposes in
their own way and you know you guys have
done it very differently and I have to
say they were so incredible in the
proposal room they had the very tough
job of being the first couple up and we
were laughing about it earlier because
holly was so confident she walked into
the room I don't think you were bet you
were barely sat down before the words
out of your mouth what figures what so
you you proposed in public it was yeah
did you know it was happening p no no he
had no chance to hold the whole the
whole scenario we got into the sim
review room that i was led to believe
what it was you know and then to sat
down and before I actually sat down
she's already speaking out by the way
it's not a food review so I think oh
okay right so you're happy that you are
marrying a very sneaky woman yeah
well I've been rethinking the whole
thing no I am I any inkling at all
because he literally had known he was
the photographer video the video will
tell you exactly how much of a night and
also I'm interested no did you practice
beforehand where you know this because I
think there's a lot of pressure and guys
you know I got recently engaged and I
know that my other half now he told me
afterwards he was so nervous he was a
rehearsing rehearsing rehearsing it on
and then when it came to it he
completely forgot to get down on one
knee and got done two knees exactly but
but it was still amazing moment but did
you not feel in our own actually went in
there nice i'm just have to win it
because i think i'll always be over
think it you then would be super diverse
was I just thought yeah lady she went so
I've got a question to ask you will you
marry me and here's a hook just haven't
really quickly so I just thought if I
have to prepare a speech or like it's
just not very me did you have a room no
no I didn't know we should we go study
but um we have a link we're dating we're
beating up a bit wicked goodness daddy's
awesome oh well look I think it's
however you do it I think it's not
easily so romantic congratulations to
you yeah thank you very MUC for November
Oh Clank hope it's a nice date will be a
lovely day MJ to thank you thank you as
well I'm the need to get nazanin fried
magazine though there you go you stay
with this August okay June now that's
the referendum same sort of thing really
stay with this Iran sunrise is still to
come